you mentioned you were running the
agency as a lifestyle company yes what
do you mean by that so I think there are
four games that you can play in business
oh love it what are they I think one of
the games is the artist game and that's
where you are you're the talent you've
got this art you've got this craft
you've got something you do that's
different to how anyone else does it and
it's magical and the goal of this game
is for you to do as much of your art as
possible and everyone you hire their
goal is to take away the friction and do
all the admin so that all you need all
you can do is Rock up and do what you do
and they take care of everything else so
that's the artist game you could do that
forever yeah pretty good game the other
game is the lifestyle game so this is
the one that I was definitely playing
for most of my agency's life and this is
where your goal is to make a certain
monthly amount say but try and do that
as passively as possible so you work as
little as possible and that money comes
in and you spend your time doing
whatever you want so for me it was
traveling and it was competing in
powerlifting um and doing kind of other
stuff other than running the business
because the goal of the business is to
fund your
lifestyle and then I think there's the
performance game and that's what I'm
definitely playing now and this is about
seeing what you're capable of so in this
game you are probably prepared to forgo
elements of your lifestyle because it
doesn't matter quite as much so whether
you get to the beach one day a week or
five days a week doesn't matter as much
as growing your business to be really
impressive or make the most impact
possible or make the most money possible
or whatever your goal is and then I
think those three games can all be
infinite games you could play all of
those forever because you could always
tend towards being a worldclass artist
or you could keep going with the
lifestyle game and just make your
lifestyle amazing or you could just see
what you could reach in terms of
performance and become a billionaire but
then the fourth game is the build it and
sell it game
not an infinite game has a probably like
a three-year lifespan or however long
you're going to do it but that is your
goal you're going to get in and you're
going to get out and that is the game
that's cool let's explore okay I'd love
to dive more into into these cuz I think
I'm playing some combination of the
artist game and the lifestyle game
and I am currently in a bit of a dilemma
where about a year ago Dan Priestley our
mutual friend came over and he was like
you know told us the difference between
lifestyle and performance and I was like
cool lifestyle all the way
but now I'm starting to feel like I also
want impact and if I could wave a magic
wand and 10x are revenue and our impact
and our profits I wouldn't say no to
that so it's like I'm not I'm not sure
if I want to play the lifestyle game or
but I'm not I definitely want to keep
doing the artist thing because if I free
up my time I'm not going to travel and
do powerlifting I'm just going to make
more videos cuz I just love the artist
side of things but I also want a Chill
Lifestyle but I also want impact and so
like I kind of want to have all three
slices of this cake how how would you go
about like I'm yeah this is a struggle
I'm having right now I think the wave of
magic one question is the exact right
question to ask because that will help
you decide which one comes first I feel
like you're not playing the lifestyle
game I think you are but I think if
someone said to you you can get all your
dream guests that we've just talked
about on your podcast and it would mean
that you couldn't go on holiday for a
year you'd be like yeah I do that yeah I
don't really care about going on holiday
yeah or whatever like whatever comes as
part of your dream lifestyle I feel like
would you would forgo that but I feel
that's because you've got the artist
identity at the same time you know
you're on something you're on an upward
trajectory you're seeing what you're
capable of at the same time I don't
think you're playing the lifestyle game
I think I might be playing the artist
game then because as you were saying
that like the goal is for me the goal is
to get everyone in the team to deal with
everything other than reading learning
and making videos yeah which is the
thing that I love doing yeah and I would
just do more and more of that if I had
if I if I had 100 million in the bank I
would still read learn and make videos
and do podcast cuz it's just fun okay so
just for you we're going to invent this
fifth category oh nice and it's called
the artist performance game okay and
that's just both that's where you're
maybe you're an artist of like next
level where you can treat it as a
performance game at the same
time because you know you know what
you're good at you've subtracted the
stuff you're not good at you know what
you can double down on like if I said to
you okay how do you T next your business
you could probably tell me because you
thought about it as a performance
business at the same time so you've
almost you are the artist but you're not
like you're not like the starving artist
you're the artist who can zoom out see
themselves and then go how do I turn
this artist into a performance
business that's interesting this is the
first time I've thought about it in that
way H cuz I guess I thought I wanted a
lifestyle business because but what I
actually wanted was to free up my time
to focus on the art yeah of making
videos and writing books and stuff M I
don't want the lifestyle business so
that I can work four hours a week and
chill on a beach and travel around and
stuff yeah and if I do do traveling
around and stuff I'm like great let me
chill in a library all day in like a
different country so I can do more
reading and make more stuff I mean
there's an argument to say that that's
because you know how you're motivated
and you've also found your purpose
because I think part of the reason I
wanted to do the lifestyle business was
because I wasn't I liked my business but
I wasn't so right now I'm like oh my God
this is going to take over the world and
I don't know if the business I was
running then I almost was out growing it
as I was building it and therefore the
lifestyle things sounded more exciting
because we go with whatever is going to
give us the most sense of progress or
the most open mean and maybe it wasn't
the business itself it was more the
lifestyle sides that's what I tended
towards interesting so if you'd won the
lottery you wouldn't continue running a
social media marketing agency it'd be
like great sorted yeah I think so
whereas now if you won the lottery you
my life would change continue doing the
software stuff yeah I think that's a
really good question if you WN the
lottery would your life change and if
it's a yes then it's like you're
probably not living your dream life
right
now if you were in the lottery would
your life change I wouldn't make any
courses okay and I I wouldn't do any
sponsorships yes okay uh and I would
reduce the frequency of uploads mhm
because currently our frequency of
uploads is like based on growth and
metrics and like sponsors and
stuff but my calendar would not change
very much I would still do the same
stuff hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye-bye